hallo mein name ist luca letztlich
bekommen wir heute zu einem neuen video
wird ja freundes dienstag und dienstag
ist ja der tag von minecraft beta lässt
regiert haben das video das letzte mal
geändert dass ihr was ich leider schon
wieder so einen scheiß wir stand letzte
mal hier unten drin und haben gehofft
dass wir vielleicht irgendwie schlafen
gehen können allerdings sind leider
überall monster lauert in die kommentare
geschrieben dass es daran lag dass wir
nur einen block quasi frei hatten bisher
die oberwelt anfängt deswegen versuche
ich jetzt mal so befinde mich jetzt ein
blog tief unter der erde ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob es jetzt klappt ich
könnte mir sogar forscher was willst du
denn da ich meine kuh ich finde es cool
dass du ja auf mich wartet aber wird es
mich ja nicht zu erschrecken müssen
ich höre irgendwo eine spinne wo ist die
du scheiß paypal die schwere dieses
jahres geht die ba bleibt noch mal da
stehen mann ich will dass diese kuh in
dieses loch da unten geht so dass wir
uns irgendwann zu eigen machen können
und die irgendwie dann bei uns bleibt
doch halt dein maul wir scheißen wir
erstmal auf die cool und begeben uns
wieder zurück zu unserem auch knochen
wir haben letzte mal hier diesen weg
gebaut und wollen jetzt hier rüber gehen
deswegen nehmen wir unsere wurden place
und diese wurden place und diese wurden
klenks und ja gehen jetzt darüber quasi
ich brauche hier einfach mal wieder
genau den gleichen weg lang den ich auch
hier vorne darüber gebaut haben dann
haben wir quasi hier zwischen irgendwie
so diese blöden kühl verfolgen ich halte
auch ich muss ehrlich gesagt zugeben ich
habe jetzt noch nicht so viele
kommentare unter den letzten folgen
gelesen weil dort echt so viel
geschrieben wurde so viele tipps
allerdings auch wirklich sehr viele
leute die man minecraft warum schild
sind das sind wieder ich meine ich kann
es wirklich alltäglich sagen ich will
das machen was mir spaß macht und dieses
projekt macht mir irgendwie spaß
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich spiel
minecraft und wir sind jetzt auch glaube
ich eben
es war natürlich wieder klar dass ich
mich viel zu hoch gebaut
unser bisheriges haus sieht jetzt nun
quasi so aus wir haben zwei wege
übereinander und ich will jetzt quasi
nur dazwischen mein haus bauen
ich weiß aber noch nicht genau wie ich
das mache ich denke ich werde erstmal
hier runter gehen und jetzt einfach
circa genau da wo wir hier drunter sind
also genau
das müsste jetzt sicher die mitte seien
schon wieder lag wir haben jetzt hier
eine fläche zwischen den beiden brücken
das heißt ich mache jetzt hier darüber
das ganze auch noch mal ja wo super cool
was aber ich kann auch überhaupt kein
deutsch heute wieder ist die komplette
folge einfach hier passiert er wieder
nichts ich verspreche euch wir gehen
demnächst an höhlen allerdings muss ich
jetzt erst mal wirklich ganz kurzem ein
trautes heim irgendwie bin ich denn
komplett b es kann doch nicht so schwer
sein dort einen scheiß blog daran zu
setzen so genauso hier jetzt und jetzt
hier noch ein und ich kann ich bauen
eine ewigkeit später okay wir haben
unsere zwei ebenen übereinander
das hat jetzt ein bisschen gedauert ich
habs jetzt allerdings hingekriegt so und
jetzt wollte ich hier so dicke
baumstümpfe allerdings von ganz unten
bis nach ganz oben durch
fragt mich nicht ob das nachher gut
aussieht ich brate mir jetzt hier erst
mal kurz ein bisschen was zu essen und
pakete ganzen und wichtige sachen rein
die ich vorerst erstmalig benötigen wir
freundlich will jetzt ein stück fleisch
essen und es kommen einfach keine sau
diese kuh da unten fakt mich echt ab
alter was will die denn hier die ganze
das ist mein puls du kriegst du bestimmt
auch rein
wir haben hier vorne ja immer noch unser
mops borna da setzt jetzt einfach mal
hier um auch noch fackel drauf und hier
ich glaube jetzt müsst ihr nämlich
ausgeleuchtet sein wie reisen und so ein
paar sachen haben wir nur eine kiste wie
sparsam sind die denn es nach draußen es
ist wundervoll ich kann jetzt
wahrscheinlich nicht mal mehr bei mir im
bett da oben schlafen weil das wie gab
nicht ausgeleuchtet ist oder so ab auf
die plattform und ich wie soll ich denn
jetzt hier schlafen 2000 jahre später es
ist wirklich komplett egal was die
ganzen hardcore spieler jetzt von meiner
taktik gehalten aber ich brauche mich
wirklich jetzt hier so einen nur damit
ich gegen die schlafen
doch kann ich da drauf setzen einfach
wirte funktioniert bitte funktioniere
einfach bitte hier ist kein fucking
sklaven
es ist toll ich werde jetzt wirklich in
dieser höhle hier reingehen und einfach
mal schauen ob wir hier vielleicht noch
irgendwie gut dass ich immer so tolle
höhlen finde einem ob alle hierfür
brauchen wir noch später das einzige was
ich jetzt erstmal brauche es vielleicht
ein bisschen eisen so dass ich mir
irgendwelche gegenstände mal machen kann
und hier mehr direkte würde
schönen guten tag
und da bin ich direkt schon wieder
draußen ich nehme jetzt einfach mal die
kohle hier noch kompletten mit damit war
was suchst du denn hier da gehe ich
einfach eine höhle findet dabei ein
fucking scharf was da steht schubst ihn
wahrscheinlich gleich noch irgendwo hier
runter auf gott
halo spiele die du doch einfach mal da
unten runter dann sehen wir jetzt mal
auf die spinne lauten vielleicht
gefährlich ist oder ob die liebe ist
unser scharfes gerade gestorben
natürlich wird ein anderer erzählte mein
gott ok ich bin ich bin ich bin mein
gott einen krügerrand eine spinne und
eine spinne und eine spinne und eine
spinne und einen krieg in kryta gruber
und noch ein thrombin zombie okay okay
okay alles der aua aua aua aber noch
einen treffer da vorne kommt noch ein
von midas ist ultra liebt das jetzt auf
einmal alle hier so von einer kommentar
seit überzeugt seid super ach und noch
einen krieg wir kümmern uns hier ein
anderes mal drum ich baue mir mal hier
eine treppe hoch scheck einfach mal
wieder ab natürlich würden jetzt auch
andere youtuber dann kommen ihre taktik
gehen dass man anderes mal wenn ich ein
bisschen ausgestattet bin ich habe jetzt
auf jeden fall erstmal ein bisschen
eisen gönnen können 8,3 sie wieder der
kollege vom schaf tut mir leid aber den
kolleginnen gestorben
wir laufen jetzt einfach mal zurück nach
marokko
um mal ganz kurz
worauf mein gott das waren ganz okay
alles gut um mal ganz kurz die situation
gerade zusammen zu fassen ich wollte
nach hause laufen habe dort einen blöden
clipper gesehen da sind eben wie dort
versteckt hatte ich den zurückgelaufen
genau in die höhle sein der mir
hinterher alles so wegen dir freunde ich
bin wirklich gerade übel am schwitzen
ich bin total fertig gerade ich weiß
nicht warum das einzige was ich heute
geschafft habt ihr diese beiden flächen
zu bauen und ein bisschen was zu
erkunden aber denn im letzten sehen
wollte was produktives dann guckt euch
alles andere auf youtube an aber nicht
bei mir an dieser stelle würde ich diese
folge minecraft beta letztlich auch
beenden wenn es euch gefallen würde ich
mich über eine bewertung freund schreibt
mir mal in die kommentare falls sie
reden habe bezüglich meines hauses und
allgemein welche sachen ich noch machen
sollen diese letzte und dann sehen wir
uns nächsten dienstag ich gehe